number three uh 60 minutes about 30
years behind the times
apparently ran a segment this weekend
talking about some of the issues with
title ix
and uh here it is listen to this
minnesota insists that financial
pressure isn't the only reason sports
are being dropped
it also cites title ix the federal law
that requires schools to match the
gender makeup of their student bodies
in their sports teams so if 54 percent
of students are women
54 percent of athletes should be too
to get to that balance schools often
choose to cut
men's sports rather than create new ones
for women
title ix is often the scapegoat when
universities cut teams
again it's to protect the core business
which is football
but you can kind of use this gender
justice
shield to kind of throw
men's non-revenue sports under the bus
football is often what gets universities
in trouble with title
ix in the first place minnesota has 115
men on his football roster
which means it needs 115 female athletes
just to balance that single sport
yeah like i said about 30 years behind
the times but it's glad they're finally
catching on um of course this is a this
is a total travesty
i mean it's completely ridiculous you
have 150 men on a sport means you have
150 women
why why why sh who says who
well i know who says it but why what's
the reason
i'll tell you the real reason why there
aren't as many women
playing sports just because and not as
many people interested in women
not as many women want to play sports a
lot more men want to play sports
also uh men are better at playing sports
most sports anyway
and so it's more fun to watch them
why do more people watch men's
basketball over women's basketball
because men are better at it
and so it's just a lot more fun to watch
it's a lot more fun to watch basketball
where people can touch the rim
that's the reality yeah it might hurt
your feelings it might not i don't care
it's just it's just it's just a simple
reality
this idea that everything has to be
equal you know i raise my kids i mean
this is something
in every parent you go through this with
my with my kids
um especially the twins that and all
kids do this
they're constantly insisting that
everything has to be equal oh he
you you gave he he has a 16 cheez-its in
his bowl that you gave him
and i only have 13. i need three more
cheez-its
well with that i'm impressed because
that's good math and then i might reward
you for doing the math
but uh in principle the message from
parents is not everything's gonna be
equal all the time
you gotta get over you gotta grow up
that's that's not the way
life works sometimes someone gets a
little more jesus than you do
that's life move on so that's the
message that
anyway that competent parents or people
who at least are trying to be competent
parents
that's the message we give our kids then
they go out into society
and they're told i don't know everything
has to be exactly equal you got 150
men playing a sport you got to have 150
women
equal this idea of equality
um is one of the worst things
that's happened to western civilization
i would put it that way
i'll tell you equality exists really in
two realms okay equality exists as
a sort of mathematical concept you know
two plus two
equals four the same as so
we could talk about equality when we're
talking about mathematical
uh when we when we're in the realm of
math
and then we can also talk about equality
when we're talking about the inherent
dignity and worth of human beings and
that's
and that's what's meant in our founding
documents when the fountain when our
founding fathers talked about equality
that's what they meant that all people
have the same inherent
worth but that's it as far as equality
among people
that's as far as it goes you have the
same inherent worth as anybody else
there's no one out there who's more of a
person than you
that that's what is meant by it so a
really good example of what happens when
people don't have equality
you have unborn babies who are killed a
million a year 60 million
babies just slaughtered and thrown into
the into into the uh dumpster
outback the medical waste stumps are or
sold for parts by planned parenthood
that's what happens when we're not
recognizing the inherent worth of a
human being and we're saying that oh
well
they're not like as people-y as we are
we're a little bit more person than them
so when people don't have that kind of
equality that's very bad and horrible
things happen all throughout history
but once we've established that that's
it
that's as far as equality goes men and
women have the same
uh inherent worth and dignity great
that's that's it with equality we could
put equality on the shelf now
once we've established that with men and
women we can put equality on the shelf
we've got that covered
there is no more equality men and women
are not equal in any other sense except
for that
and any attempt to make them equal in
any sense except that really basic and
really spiritual sense will will will
lead to absurdities
at best
because the reality is whether you know
man woman whatever you sitting there
watching this me sitting right here
you know as for me every single every
person in this building right now
they are either smarter than me or
dumber than me
they're stronger they're weaker like
it's
we are not equal in any way for better
or worse
from where i'm sitting just the way it
goes you got to get used to it
or apparently you don't have to get used
to it that's the problem you know this
is the
the this message that we give kids all
the time we've got society working
against us
because we're always telling kids well
you know you get into the real world and
you just got it you got to deal with
these things
but then the real world comes along and
says i don't know they don't have to
deal with it
we're going to keep the delusion going
we want your kids to remain
kids forever not in a good way by the
way of like protecting their innocence
no no because
we're we're gonna make sure they see
pornography at the age of eight
but uh so in that sense we're gonna take
their innocence away from them but
in sense in the sense of their emotional
maturity
well you know that we want them to be
childlike forever well i hope you
enjoyed that clip from the matt walsh
show if you did go ahead and hit that
subscribe button right down there so you
can stay up to date on
all of our future content